by using the term spontaneous happiness
I want to call attention to the fact
that we can open ourselves to the
possibility of happiness by doing
various things and then when that occurs
we should be grateful for it but I'm
rather suspicious of pursuing happiness
as a goal the word happiness comes from
an Old Norse root that means luck or
fortune which suggests that people
traditionally have associated happiness
with external fortune I don't that's a
good place to to look for it and in fact
if I ask most people what will make them
happy most people think it's getting
something that they don't have you know
a new car a better job lover and my
sense is that that's not what we should
be striving for first of all when you
get it the the feeling that you're
looking for often is very short-lived I
think instead we should be working for
contentment and contentment to me is an
inner sense of fulfillment that's
relatively independent of external
circumstances now interestingly there
are very consistent reports and many of
you may have be able to connect this
with your own experience that people who
go to other areas of the world that are
much less affluent than ours where
people have much less are very struck by
the fact that people are more content
and there seems to be a very clear
correlation between material affluence
and deteriorating contentment that's
just a fascinating observation the more
people have the less content they seem
to be
and I'd also would emphasize that I
think our moods are supposed to vary you
know we're not supposed to be up here
all the time everything in our
experience varies and I think it is good
to be accepting of these natural cycles
and mood that doesn't mean you mean
obviously don't want to go so far down
that you don't remember what it's like
back up here and you don't want to get
stuck in the bottom but I think it is
natural to cycle through this also I've
come across some other very interesting
research from the relatively new field
of evolutionary psychology which
attempts to explain our mental states
and evolution
terms that sees value in depression and
even suggests that natural selection may
have chosen a depressive trait in human
beings and the reasoning of these
evolutionary psychologists is this the
essence of depression is a very strong
inward focus and a tendency to chew over
and over ace the same thought pattern
you know which lead is negative it makes
you sad makes you fearful so forth
that's called depressive rumination in
psychology and it's seen as being a
pathological trait but the evolutionary
psychologists suggest that that's
exactly the mental strategy that favors
problem solving and creativity and that
people who do this are you know either
you're faced with a really difficult
problem you sort of can't stop thinking
about you chew it over and over until
you either decide there's no solution
give up or you find the solution and so
it may be that evolution favoured this
kind of trait in us and that may also
help explain why we see such a strong
correlation between depression and
creativity you know I could spend the
whole time talking to you here about the
incredibly famous and successful artists
writers composers people in all fields
who have been seriously affected by
depression you know many of whom have
turned to alcohol or drugs to treat that
some of whom have committed suicide but
that cries out for explanation and why
is there such a strong association
between depression and creativity and
the answer may be somewhere in here that
you know tolerating a you know a certain
amount of depression or being
comfortable with you know low moods from
time to time there may be value in them
[Music]